hello everyone
we will be starting the meeting in
couple of minutes
thank you for your patience
hello everyone uh welcome to the webinar
uh the webinar will start in five more
minutes in the meantime you can
introduce yourself in the chat section
and get to know the participants
hello
uh am i ordering
all right yes
yes yes you are
all right thank you let's start the
webinar hello everyone a very warm
greeting to one and all my name is shri
gavi krishna gummar and i'm a research
intern at find biotech i would also be
the host for the webinar for today so to
begin with i would like to welcome you
all to today's webinar on omics logic
bioinformatics and data science research
fellowship program
before getting into the further details
i would like to briefly talk about the
program
the research fellowship program has been
designed to help young researchers and
students take advantage of the
bioinformatics resources for analysis of
complex life science data and become
well-versed in bioinformatics the
research fellows participate in
cutting-edge bioinformatics research led
by expert mentors
the fellowship program will offer a
combination of online resources and
mentor guidance to prepare you and help
you complete a bioinformatics project
the registration fees will cover the
cost of training mentorship and big data
server the platform is a cloud-based
analytical server used by research labs
and independent scientists around the
world
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me introduce you to the team behind
the program we are a us-based
bioinformatics company who is working
with multiple academic and commercial
collaborators to develop easy-to-use
analytical tools and our mission is to
make bioinformatics more accessible
the omixlogic training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries in over 300 workshops
due to this fast growth
our team is working with local and
regional coordinators that are helping
refine local program logistics and
leverage our online training resources
adapting them to the needs of students
and researchers around the world
the omics logic program follows a
project-based learning approach using
research grade tools to analyze data
from top peer-reviewed journals the
omics logic training has been completed
by participants from 162 countries in
over 300 workshops for six different
specialization tracks ranging from
oncology infectious diseases precision
medicine neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and comprehensive
training on omix data analysis
[Music]
as a result we have acquired
professional certification to offer and
curriculum and support research projects
using our omics logic project-based
character
together with our existing modules for
which you will gain access to the omics
logic portal where you can try and
explore these modules exercises in
pipeline building coding and various
methods of analysis using project
sources from peer review publications
today we will discuss about the research
specialization tracks program structure
outcomes of the program take your
queries and listen to our research
fellows projects
also we will take you through the
program resources and help you get
started with your training and research
journey
so first of all let's begin by signing
up on the omix logic learn portal
to do this
you can visit this website i am sharing
the link in the chat box
[Music]
so once everyone has the link open and
ready we can continue
[Music]
please comment yes so that i can proceed
okay great
so
let's begin
so once you uh come to the website you
will see on the top right corner
uh the tab that says login click on that
one
[Music]
if you already have an existing account
please sign in to your account otherwise
we'll create an account
so to create an account you will be
asked to enter three main details your
name your email id and your password
or you also have an option to join using
your social media handles that includes
your google account facebook account
your apple id github account and your
twitter
[Music]
so i'll pause for a while once you
create an account and login please let
me know and we can login together
all right so
since i already have an account created
i'm going to sign in using my existing
email id and password
once you log in you should be seeing
this the number of courses that are
offered on the storage portal
and on the top right corner you should
be seeing a tab that says welcome back
with your email id click on that tab
and you should be redirected to the
profile setting page
here you should have and you should see
an option to upload your profile feature
your link your social media handles as
well as
provide a brief description about
yourself
and this way the like-minded researchers
and students in the field can get in
touch with you and connect with you
all right
[Music]
so once we have this uh i would like to
invite dr raghvan
who will be talking about the program
structures specialization fields with
example research fellow projects
to give a brief background about dr
raghvan lakshmi narayan he is an
accomplished computational biologist
with more than four years of research
experience in subject areas like
multi-organic data analysis
and data science methods in precision
oncology and protein or dna structural
bioinformatics with a strong background
in bio and
bioinformatics and biophysics he earned
his phd in computational biology from
the max plant institute germany
so please i would like to invite drag
vane dancer to
for explaining the further details of
the project
thank you thank you very much sri gauri
let me find ways to share the stream
know
okay i think we should work one stretch
[Music]
okay thank you very much sri gauri for
very nice introduction you don't have to
so
i also got confirmation that
participants can see my screen
and i still cannot see the screen
it's that
okay
then both you and me both of us can see
the screen so welcome everybody uh to
this
yeah welcome everybody to this webinar
and i'm raghavindran i'm a research
consultant and bioinformatics mentor
with prime biotic and i will be your
mentor throughout your research
fellowship program so i'm very excited
to share with you how this program works
and we will answer
some specific questions related to what
is this program about and how to join
the program how to submit a project on
our mixed logics and
what are the general structure of the
program that will help you perform your
own bioinformatic research
with us
so this program can be roughly divided
into three main straight stages so at
the first stage is a training stage so
this is a stage which sets the direction
for participants or students like you to
define in which area or in which
research field that you are going to
work on so some of you might have a very
clear idea on which field or which
research topic that you want to work on
and some of you might have also had some
introduction to bioinformatics as a
course or as a curriculum what is a
different uh
introduction means
so uh but some of you also would like to
gain more knowledge before making a good
decision so for those who are still
deciding and who doesn't who still are
not from a bioinformatics background
we always suggest you to start with very
two very basic courses that is
introduction to bioinformatics and bytes
and modules so these basic courses are
designed to introduce the basic concepts
of bioinformatics and this application
to different research fields or areas
that employs various omics types mixed
data types which can be subjected to
multitude of analysis methods so we are
introducing you
several methods so by the end of these
two introductory courses you should be
able to understand what are the
different methods employed for different
commerce comics data types and also you
also should have a clear
idea of in which field or in which data
type or in what question that you want
to
work on not question at least a focus on
which direction that you want to move so
at the end of the first stage you should
be able to for example
have all the necessary uh
skill sets to identify specific research
question that you would want to work on
so in this
stage where you are going to identify a
research topic so um
you will have to first find a data set
that has the potential to answer your
research question
so um
more on this little later so in the next
stages where you actively pursue you
pursue your research discussing vessels
inferences and
all the necessary suggestions and
feedbacks from mentors all along right
there
so after these three uh very important
phrases you will have to prepare a
presentation that you will submit in our
portal biomix logix portal as a project
so that you can showcase this project
and share with your network appears and
share
your poster if you have prepared in
conferences and in meetings scientific
meetings that you cannot
so let's again
go through for okay for example um
sorry i think it's not stopping at one
point yeah so we uh over throughout the
course of this uh
throughout the course of this uh
this program we have a weekly progress
report form that you will have to fill
up and submit to us and you will have to
discuss your progress with the mentor at
least once in a week so these progress
reports are excellent
way to evaluate how you progress through
the research fellowship program it is
helpful for you and also helpful for us
to find or to
place you where you are currently and
then to help you in at all the necessary
steps of
your research progress
so our learning resources for this
program includes
various courses that cover different
specialization fields so we have
specialization fields like that focuses
on the bioinformatics parts of the omics
field or a mixed data type that you
would want to start with like if you
want to work with metagenomics then you
can start with metagenomics courses if
you want to work with transcriptomics
you can start with transcriptomic course
that both of these courses and also
other ones goes in depth
in
in the type of data that you are going
to analyze and the various different
options of analysis methods that you
will employ for different questions and
different answers that you are pursuing
from these data types
so you can also decide on
different data science skillsets that
you want to start developing so that you
can apply to various comics data type in
general so for those who would want to
go through skill set development
fields or specialization we have a
multiple
coursework that explains or that
introduces you to python environment and
our environment and different data
science applications and machine
learning which includes machine learning
and deep learning methods so all of
these methods can be generally applied
to various data types that one can
obtain from several uh analysis methods
that that are designed specifically for
different comics data types
so uh
what one example of how these forces are
designed uh
let's uh let's take a look at designing
a bioinformatics research project
courses so these courses are designed to
take you deeper into those specific
respective topics in a step-by-step
process that are outlined into separate
lessons so for example this is a course
which we suggest to all the participants
so that they can uh
understand the necessary steps involved
in how to design a bioinformatics
project so more on this a little later
so also throughout these courseworks we
have several practical assignments along
the coursework and example projects that
takes data from publicly available
resources and the data that are used in
popular research
articles
and we will design as separate analysis
pipelines or separate analysis methods
that is going to answer a research
question that is
not
straight
that is not related to
what was the focus of the research paper
so we will take the data and then try to
combine different analysis methods in
employing or in using these
publicly available resources to answer
the search question on our own so while
you are going through these example
projects you will get a a good
understanding of how to take a publicly
available data and how to create your
own analysis methods that is going to
answer a specific question or hypothesis
that you will form from basically
understanding
some interaction about the data
as described in the associated paper or
publications so these different exemplar
projects
are
designed to include variety of topics
like in epigenetics human health
agriculture biology immunology precision
medicine etcetera etcetera a lot of
different parts so also microbiome also
so these practical exercises and
these projects will give you necessary
exposure to understand the data driven
discovery of real research
behind these projects and it will also
encourage you
to think critically about how to
go about designing your own projects and
what are the necessary ingredients in
creating a successful bioinformatics
project so
as i mentioned the net the basic purpose
of the fundamental purpose of doing
these practical assignments is to
get a deep understanding of data
specific challenges and also to
showcase how various methods are methods
of analysis are applied in real-world
situations so when you compare the
results that you obtain
with the one that are focus of the
publication then you can clearly
understand how
the questions are formulated to
get to the publication level from such a
publicly available data or such a vast
quantity of data and that is delta here
so this can be your project at the end
and of this analysis also so once you
have acquired all the necessary skills
and you are performing your research in
a
you know good healthy progress and then
you can use these skills to apply them
to various different research problems
that shapes the
bioinformatics and the biological
research of today so it can be from
physician medicine it can be from
population health can even be space and
astrobiology so we have various example
projects that
that are categories under different such
different categories so it will give you
all the necessary introduction to
take the data from these specific fields
and then apply your own analysis methods
for the
question that you are interested in
trying to ask from those data so
let's start going through how would you
find it such topic so let's let's take a
practical approach to um how to
get a or how to identify a research
topic so um
as we said the major steps that are
important to design a research problem
that we have been discussing so far is
first you have to frame the problem and
then uh
to frame the problem you have to
understand what is the latest current
trend in that specific problem so you
can by training the problem like you can
try to
narrow down but i want to work on cancer
or you want to be even more specific i
want to work on let's say head and neck
cancer and then
you can understand the literature or you
can go through the literature review the
literature
the scientific uh
results for the last five years or even
last 10 years on this specific topic so
once you have gone through the
literature you can then identify
that specific gap so
the literature review should tell you
what are the areas that are addressed
more frequently or more in a very
detailed manner and also it should also
give you a hint on what are the areas
that are not covered generally so you
can try to
approach that area or try to take that
specific area and then
collect a raw data that will
or you can actually find publicly
available resources uh data that is
necessary to answer your question or
your problem or answer the gap in
literature that you have identified so
far so once you have collected these
data then you have to create a processes
of data sequences to create a pipeline
for the analysis
detailed analysis of this data and then
you can yeah you start by exploring the
data to understand the patterns and then
you perform in-depth analysis that you
have designed for the data
once your analysis is complete then you
infer from the results and then perform
necessary uh biological implications by
relating it to the
characteristics of the sample are to the
nature of the problem that you started
with so
for example in hidden neck
cancer that i started with i may have
started with
trying to categorize the tumor tissues
so if i can collect the necessary data
that will help me in categorizing or
classifying the tumor tissues into
multiple categories then i have to find
whether my analysis substance treats
this claim or substantiates of
hypothesis and once my analysis and my
inferences are complete then i can
put together this as a story and
communicate the results to the peers
so let's start how to find a topic or
how to choose a topic so you always
start with topics that you know about or
topics that you care about and
etc for example this could be a personal
reason or this could be a reason that
you are deeply interested in so um you
can start by
noting down or actually by
collecting few slides or a few
information uh about the background
about the topic background so uh
then you have to start preparing or
start spending uh
few time in analyzing or researching the
topic so how much has been known so what
has been studied and
among those what is studied what is left
to be studied and what will be
interesting in this
in this topic that will be interesting
to the audience and that will be
interesting to you also so you have to
do something that you also care about
and then once uh these is narrowed down
and then you have to find uh a data that
is going to answer the question that you
can choose from this uh
from the in this topic for example
if the topic is very specific or very uh
narrow down you might not find
sufficiently
studied data or sufficient volume of
data that will answer your wealth or if
the topic is too
wide or too broad you might find a lot
of data and you will be left with a
lot of choices to uh
uh make a good decision so uh you you
have to find the right balance that
that will maximize or that will help you
in identifying the data perfect data
that will um
answer the query that you have in your
mind so how to do this for example um
so
finding right questions or right sources
are are one of the issues so this is
always a back and forth
process where for example in the
for example in the original research you
take the raw data and then you perform
the analysis and then you compile
different analysis and then you find a
solution or you can also go back you can
take from the publicly available
resources and uh collect date
compiled databases and then you explore
for the possible
trends and then from these trends you
can actually design a question whether
the initial question that i have in mind
can be substantiated by uh following
some of the trends so we will get an ex
example for this in a while
so uh
for example um
if you
uh
to
narrow down on the topic of research
identification or topic identification
you first
go through the reviews and then you can
categorize those reviews on on uh on
their
analysis methods on the or different
questions that they are answering and
then once you have a thorough meta
analysis done or thorough analysis done
on the reviews that are available or the
publication that i've done for the last
let's say two or five years of the data
then for your topic then you can
identify the unanswered questions and
you can identify the gaps and you can
also identify some of the debates and
controversies which are left unanswered
in the in this topic so this these are
the areas which you need to focus on i
mean on the areas which are
obviously answered by many people you
don't want to reinvent the wheel so we
want to identify those areas which are
not
covered a lot and
which has lot of potential to
improve the science or which has a lot
of potential to fill the gaps in the
science
in that particular research area so that
gap and how to
answer how to design a specific analysis
methods to
answer those caps or answers to some
answer question will define your
hypothesis or question so you always
start with trying to find a topic so
these are often um
used are the resources that are often
used are ncbi i mean repositories like
pubmed and bio projects and gene
expression omnibus these are all the um
and sra these are the repositories where
you will find publicly available data so
you can start with a pubmed and then
look for a search for
some of the topics that that
that uh
excites you and for example let's say
that if i want to uh work on sars so
obviously sars and corona virus uh these
topics are famous for the last two or
three years
era so um once you understand different
questions and different uh reviews that
are done on stars maybe you will find a
very interesting topic so um
and they say uh this topic
of understanding the imbalance host
response to a coronavir infection so uh
is is the one that excites you so what
what do you do so you you start to find
uh
data sets that will that are either
associated with this publication are a
data set that are associated with host
response to sas infection so if you find
data sets that are associated with this
publication then you can explore the
data set for possible trend and that
will design your uh
query or design your question or you can
as i mentioned so generally search in
the databases mentioned above like gene
expression omniverse or sra or
bioproject databases for
host response of human uh forces
response for suspect to
infection
so uh
this
this paper has a data set associated
with that so we can see the accession
number then geo ids so we can get
through the gu id so this data set in
the gene expression omnibus data page
will give you uh some basic information
about what the data is all about and
what was what was the study design and
what was studied and what are the
samples involved and what are the
different replicates of the samples that
we can find
so
and this also gives you access or this
also gives access to
processed data
so we are not going to
perform a detailed analysis of the
process data but the process data is an
excellent place for you to start looking
for the trends that will answer your
questions so
when you take the process data and then
quickly perform a principal component
analysis to study the
sample distribution across the
transcriptomics data in this case
then you can if you uh if you can find
such trends which is uh
which can clearly separate samples that
are
that are of control type and samples
that are given or that are
um subjected to treatment from rba and
obviously so this trend gives you a lot
of promise that you can specifically
focus on for example uh responses due to
rba and responses due to rvc when
compared to the control samples so you
have to do perform such a basic
exploratory analysis on the processed
data that is available on almost all of
the
geo data assets so this could be a back
and forth process some of the dataset
might not be conducive
for
for a linear analysis like pca and some
of the dataset could be
large and
you you have to go through this process
for a couple of uh more than one data
sets that's what i more than one data
set that's what i like so um
[Music]
so uh this trend is promising so when
when we see such a promising trend so we
collect the raw data that is also linked
to uh
to the uh
sra or short read assembling database
from this geo database all of these are
uh all of these are from the one
umbrella data repository ncbi
so we collect the raw data
first queue our data and then perform
our own analysis or design our own
analysis process for the
for the raw data so why do we do that uh
we can for example
check
if difference in a couple of analysis
algorithms that we choose will change
the data or maybe we can
take the
raw data and perform our own
normalization or processing or different
processing methods and most of the
processing
downstream analysis methods that you are
going to employ will require the raw
output from
such a pipeline um of
which is a sequence of analysis that you
employ with a fast q or high throughput
sequencing so we pre-process the data
and then we map it on to the reference
genome for example and
we quantify the mrna molecules that are
mapped onto different genes so this is a
very short uh
step-by-step process of transcriptomics
analysis this is just one example of
variety of different analysis that you
can perform on comics data so this will
actually give you uh
uh or this can actually result in a
downstream analysis from which we can
learn what are the diff what are the
genes that are differentially expressed
when you compare two conditions for
example in here treatment through one
rotor virus tray or treatment to the
other doctor by the strain compared to
the control surface
so uh you can design your own analysis
method that is different from the one
that is published or
you can use an updated uh version of the
human genome
reference so you you have a variety of
different reasons to perform your own
analysis methods so uh
once you perform these analysis and get
hold of structured data then you can
start exploring the data for the
possible
patterns and well-defined patterns we
already had a hint of the trend that
could be export from the data and then
these pattern exploration or this data
exploration will tell you
the necessary transformation or
normalization that you need to perform
so that you can use variety of different
downstream analysis that will
validate your hypothesis so that will
throw right on the question that you are
working with
so yeah
so then you can perform in-depth
analysis on the structured output uh you
can perform
for example you can identify different
genes that are differentially expressed
and then from the genes you can identify
the pathways that are
enriched or you can identify
which specific
network that is
biological net
pathways and
network that is network of genes that is
involved in characterizing this response
for example and then we can also study
various different uh
biology uh of the sample like uh if your
data involves uh tria involves response
to a drug resistance on treatment
resistance and we can also study the
basic
behind this development of this
resistance from these analysis for
example
and at last you will have to after
performing the data analysis and after
performing the biological implication
implications you have to
stream all of these
in a one good story or one good project
that will link
what you have done and how you have done
it and
what you infer the most from the variety
of different
different analysis that you have
performed for the uh project so uh yeah
this and then once you have completed or
compiled the project report then you can
publish that in our
public in our nano mix logic uh portal
and um
and that will be public to many people
and you can share it with your peers and
then yeah you can also if you create a
poster like this you can also share
those poster in the
in the symposium or in
several meetings that you are going to
get
so uh
next up
we yeah here are some of the latest uh
or some of the projects that are
developed in our platform and uh which
are part of the research fellowship
program from various different uh yeah
specializations so we have uh for
example
in this case
okay this is a poster for project done
in collaboration between maguchi
memorial institute for medical research
and this poster is on malarial parasite
plasmogen falciparum and its antigen and
which is a antigen with a
rotary neck protein binding
yeah binding so the interactions sorry
so this interaction is extremely
critical for this
for the false parent to invade into host
human response human
hosts red blood cells so
different malaria vaccines are actually
we that are known to
prevent such such binding and to prevent
this
interaction and um
and
these different
candidates or these different vaccines
have variety or variable success or
variable successes at different stages
so this study actually performs a
hypotype
analysis or network analysis of genomic
sequence data
from this from the
variable infection rates and it compares
uh with the uh
uh data that is from the repository uh
from another region so uh by mapping on
to the genomic variance uh
that is uh that one identified from this
haplotype study on to the protein
structures they uh this paper or this
poster actually concludes uh that there
are some local variations and there are
some
epitope affecting variations in
geographical locations that are
different for different malaria
parasites and that needs to be taken
into consideration while ah while
developing vaccines
for malaria in a bug so and also you can
also uh
publish your results in in bio archive
preprint then you have a
paper or almost an ear publication ready
output that is available in that um
in the public and you can link it to
your orcid id and then you can
also share it with your uh
yeah share it with your peers or have it
use it for your uh future uh in
one of the best way to store your uh
almost ready uh
projects so uh
there are other ways to do this also so
you can also develop your profile and
then
this is uh this is from sinai dolaner
and who finished her projects and where
they booked and she was able to
work on
leukemia and um
and identify uh
differentially expressed genes and
protein coding genes that are involved
in
biogenesis and
of these leukemia cells and she also
identified several non-coding rnas and
that are found to be significantly
expressed on this
this culminated into a research paper so
you can you can also
publish your research if you are
if your research fellowship yields a
very promising results or if this could
be uh this could set the stage for
further analysis that could result in a
very promising paper
so yeah with that i'm open to uh some
questions and i passed this stage back
to sridhara
thank you so much sir that was really
informative if the participants have any
queries or technical challenges so far
please mention them in the chat box and
we can help resolve it
i'll wait for a couple of seconds
all right so next i would like to invite
mr ilya brodsky he is one of the
co-founders and ceo of fine biotech
his background is in applied mathematics
and data science he has facilitated and
managed collaboration with researchers
at stanford ucsf louisiana state
university and other academic and pharma
r d teams mr bronski also oversees the
strategic development of research
projects and manages the team
responsible for bioinformatic analysis
training and collaborations for pine
biotech in this part of the webinar he
will be discussing about the research
fellowship outcomes in the us
over to youngster
all right thank you sri guri and thank
you raghav for giving a good overview of
the program itself
i briefly want to mention
that you know from a perspective of
someone
that hires people with bioinformatics
backgrounds
i think it's important to understand as
a student potentially you might not
really know
what that work might look like what the
projects and what the different
challenges might be
and from the employer's perspective and
the employer here could be either in a
company
or in a lab a research lab a pi of a
research lab
they don't really know how to evaluate
someone who's coming to them and trying
to show
their resume
or trying to you know come in someone
who knows let's say bioinformatics or
even biotechnology for that matter
so in a lot of cases
when you're faced with that critical
interaction
what are some of the things that you
actually want to be able to demonstrate
one of the things that will always come
up
is
the soft skill so to stay right so how
well can you present yourself how well
can you uh answer questions or maybe
think on the spot about some question
that involves maybe a non-direct answer
right where you have to show your
ability to think
consider the different options come up
with maybe some kind of
decision that needs to be made
and because these kinds of interactions
uh can never fulfill
the role of
uh you know getting to know someone
right the the interactions are very
brief and non-conclusive
that's why your resume is not enough
that's why just coming to the interview
is not enough in a lot of cases what
happens in the graduate
you know lab where people
you know from phd level and onwards are
hired
is that people look at the quality of
your research so that might include
participation in research uh in papers
maybe recommendations from people who
have worked with you before
but for an undergraduate it's very
difficult to
get to that level you probably have
limited participation in research you
probably don't have a lot of references
to share about your ability to work in a
research environment
you probably had minimal opportunities
to conduct research from beginning to
the end and even know about all of the
different stages that go into that kind
of research
and a huge challenge for that is access
to
high quality lab environments
so as an undergraduate student you have
to go through a lot of training and
potentially be in a well-funded
institution to have access to a lot of
that kind of equipment and that's why
bioinformatics is such a critical
opportunity for those who want to
develop those kinds of skills and who
want to stand out
in terms of their capabilities when they
apply for research positions when they
apply for
positions in the industry or even when
they want to continue
their
research and study in a university
so i want to briefly
speak about
the research fellowship program that we
have
that brings the opportunity to work with
big data coming from expert labs
interact with mentors from around the
world that have the background and the
kind of track record and could
potentially
give you a recommendation letter at the
end
and also the training that we provide
which will really highlight the
different opportunities in both research
and in industry on how
okay thank you
so
um those are the three main components
of this program right and so i'll
briefly kind of show
how these three different components are
used in several different directions
that i think are very promising uh in
the world of bioinformatics where really
you can see a lot of data coming
to the forefront of biological discovery
and translational research that leads
into biotechnology pharmaceutical
industry and the clinical research
field
so
there are
kind of four of these topics that i will
briefly talk about
precision medicine population health
biotechnology and agriculture and space
and astrobiology
these four have been chosen because
the amount of data the complexity of
data and the reliance on computational
biology skills
individuals infrastructure
etc
is growing at an exponential rate
so let's first talk about precision
medicine
what we all know is when we think about
the world medicine is that at the
beginning of that journey in medicine
you meet a doctor or a nurse
and
uh you as you probably all know when you
go to a doctor you go to a clinic
the first thing that they're gonna do is
they're going to try to diagnose the
disease and diagnosing the disease is a
process that involves expertise so a lot
of experience that doctors have dealing
with this specific type of disease it
requires labs where your samples are
being sent to
identify what's going on you know what
exactly is this
and then it also has this
large field of research that constantly
is being updated because people are
finding new
meaningful insights about different
types of diseases and and conditions
that we call uh preclinical conditions
that lead to disease
so in this field of precision medicine
this whole change from
having
a few indicators that can tell us very
accurately what the disease is
that is changing to
many many more indicators that are much
more precise that's where the word
precision comes from in the term
precision medicine but also because they
are so precise they are specific to very
small groups or even individuals and
that's where the word personalized
medicine comes from
so those two parallel directions of
precision
and personalized medicine
converge in specific chronic diseases
and those could be
cancer metabolic diseases
and others and and they include a
combination of various markers that can
help us understand the risk how
predisposed someone is to have a disease
happen early on
complexity of disease progression so how
likely are they to recover fast or
develop some complications
but also importantly to two very
specific and immediate needs in this
field which is accurate diagnosis
and then effective treatment selection
because it's important to select
treatment that actually is going to be
effective
so in the world of precision medicine
bioinformatics and biomedical analytics
play a huge role because
so much data at every interaction is
being collected that someone needs to
make sense of that data
and that someone today are very
specialized genetic counselors and maybe
clinicians doctors
sorry
but ultimately this field continues to
develop and in between those
interactions there's going to be a lot
of opportunity to number one conduct
research that leads to identification of
these markers and
also
to technicians that will have to deal
with this kind of data process this data
analyze this data and be able to say
something about this data so i think
this field has a huge potential for
those of you that are interested in
medical school that are interested in md
phd programs but also that are
interested in
research that has the potential to
change the way that people are diagnosed
and treated for precision medicine the
second area that is very obviously right
now being changed in front of our eyes
is the world of public health
or population health where we see this
pandemic and others really change our
reliance on molecular diagnostics to
identify specific strains to identify
populations at more risk
to understand new approaches to vaccine
design right we're seeing it in front of
our eyes and so i think it's obvious
that in this field there's going to be a
tremendous change as we move forward in
terms of how much data and how much
analysis of that data is being done to
really be able to anticipate react more
fast to these kinds of outbreaks but
also to be able to design new
therapeutics and interventions like
vaccines to slow
the transmission of diseases
another important area is the field of
biotechnology and agriculture and kind
of combining them together but really i
want to first talk about agriculture
so as you know with climate change
there's a huge concern about the
ability of crops to remain resilient
uh with the recent increase in the
prices of fertilizers we see a lot of
people turning to
bacterial type fertilizers that change
the microbiome of the soil but because
land is so different right there's
different types of toxicity acidity
amount of water being available in
different fields
now we understand that we can
effectively measure those different
kinds of
indicators and identify the best crops
for the best portion of land
we can increase productivity
of those crops and we can make those
crops more nutritious more resilient
and uh easier to grow
and so the field of precision
agriculture is really emerging as a
field that will be dominated by data
but importantly also by omits data
you can see the number of crops that
their genomes have been sequenced to be
able to ask these questions is growing
every year
and you can see that the ability to
design new crops and make
specific features of those crops
kind of
become more attuned to the needs of a
specific region those kinds of studies
are emerging you can see a huge issue
with uh forests around the world where
they are being attacked by insects and
they're being uh you know subjected to
harsh climate conditions um and
obviously all of that ties in to the
quality of the environment that we live
in
finally
i want to briefly mention space and
astrobiology
so when we think about space we don't
typically think about
medical needs we don't think about
quality of life right i mean astronauts
go there and they train for years to be
even considered
but eventually when they're there you
know they have to deal with these very
harsh conditions and those include
conditions of microgravity
conditions of radiation
really limited food supply and diversity
of food so there's really
a
very unique
kind of combination of factors that we
know affect human health in a profound
way
and that's why there's a huge effort in
not only building technology to get us
to space but also developing
methodologies to understand how space
travel will affect health and how we can
adapt to these conditions to be able to
grow food maybe on uh the space station
uh maybe as you probably have seen the
first arabidopsis plant has recently
been grown in moon soil here on earth
but it was on in moon soil and and that
is a significant study that shows that
it is possible to grow food on the moon
theoretically
but also there have been studies about
the microbiome uh because there's an
issue with uh different types of
microbes kind of living in the space
station international space station
right so there's a huge interest and
funding available for those kinds of
studies
and in fact many of our interns and
fellows have been able to conduct
research studies using data that nasa is
actually providing free of charge to the
community at large
uh kind of encouraging students
researchers to be asking questions about
what's happening in space and how can we
understand and better prepare for the
type of space travel that is envisioned
by these base agencies
so
to
start addressing the variety of topics
that we just discussed i think uh dr
raghavendran already provided you with a
clear framework on how to be able to
address some of those questions but i
want to re review again a couple of the
slides that he already shared but
maybe focus on them in a little bit of a
different fashion so the first thing
that he mentioned was
the challenge was selecting a topic we
just saw
four major domains a lot of potential
directions and a lot of interesting
questions that could be asked and i
think as you get to know every one of
these domains and you
are able to study the research
publications out there that come out or
have come out in the recent years you
will find that a lot of those papers
they focus on organizing and
categorizing different topics relevant
to that domain so if you take the field
of precision medicine or population
health or
biotechnology and agriculture or space
omics you will find that a lot of those
kinds of experiments and studies that
have made a
a significant impact on that field will
be categorized they will say
this is what has been uh you know the
topic this is why
these are the types of experiments that
have been done to address that topic or
question
the second thing
is that in the discussion portion of
those publications you will find a lot
of times
the reviewers
and the people authors who write these
papers they will actually identify
gaps unanswered questions controversies
and debates around specific topics and
those are really
the most interesting topics that you
potentially as a student or as a
young researcher can start to think
about
a lot of those
are limited by the amount of data that
is available a lot of those are limited
by the types of experiments that are
possible to uh conduct
but this field is growing is uh
developing very rapidly and so it is
easy to imagine how
uh a publication can
only focus on a small portion of an
unanswered question and the rest of the
data that is available from the
experiment has yet to be analyzed in a
specific way to be able
to sorry to contribute to those answers
so i think that bioinformatics and the
availability of this public domain data
really allows us to leverage
these
high quality
expensive data sets that are now
publicly available to be able to ask
very specific impactful questions that
we can actually answer and i think that
this research fellowship program is
designed specifically around that kind
of need it is designed to help you
identify those
understand the context of where the
question is being asked find those data
sets and then be able to conduct
uh analysis to be able to answer those
kinds of questions
and so i i think another part of this
process is really an understanding of
where you're coming from right and this
is something that comes with experience
and this is also something that comes uh
in all areas of research right so think
about this process as something that you
potentially will experience in a
research lab preparing to conduct
impactful research
in all of these fields
you have to understand the terminology
you have to understand the different
data types how those data types are
generated and how they are processed and
analyzed
after that you have to be able to select
a topic not only that is interesting but
that you or you and the team can
actually complete in a defined period of
time
a lot of research projects last decades
and the objective of this program is not
to get you into one of those projects
the objective of these uh this three
months or six months program is really
to give you the opportunity to
ask a question and be able to answer it
with some kind of analysis in a quick
three month or six months period now you
don't have three months and six months
just to do that you have to understand
that it will take you some time to get
prepared to identify that question and
then to conduct the analysis you might
have only a month or so or maybe a month
and a half so it really has to be
planned well
and executed with uh an ability to
understand what the results will
you know look like and will mean and so
that's why we also have this practical
component here as well so to support
this process
we have a community that will actually
be able to help you along the way
guide you to the right kinds of
resources and be able to help you to
conduct the analysis and plan it in such
a way that you will be able to complete
it in a short time i'm going to skip my
next slide here that talks about the
practic uh the practical um
uh kind of alignment but but i want to
highlight um you know two specific
outcomes
for um this kind of training here in the
united states so the first example
really comes from a researcher who comes
more from a biology and biochemistry
background
dr olga dartsva now she works for a
company a pharmaceutical company but
when she joined the program she was a
part of a research lab at the roswell
park comprehensive cancer center and her
background was in
cancer and she understood that a lot of
these studies in cancer what the
biologist's role a lot of times is is to
generate the data right ask the question
maybe generate the data
and then receive the results and be able
to interpret them
and she understood that that gap between
conducting the research and giving over
the data and then getting it back right
that analysis
part of it is really the gap that she
can master on her own to get a lot more
results out of it
and because she was able to understand
the approach the logic of the analysis
and acquire some practical skills she
had two very specific outcomes and those
outcomes number one
is that she was able to use
bioinformatics in her ongoing research
and number two acquire those skills and
certify that she has the practical
ability to use those skills to advance
in her career so those are two very
practical outcomes
the second example is from a researcher
here at the louisiana state university
she was a phd student at the time so i
will vote and she actually was able to
identify the specific types of data that
she might be using in her ongoing
research and actually that opened a
whole new opportunity for her to be able
to pursue this in a more serious way
so early in her phd
she was able to try out a lot of
different tools right as you saw already
displayed we have a lot of different
pipelines that are focused on the logic
of the analysis and in a short period of
time you might not have the time to
really learn a lot of the technical
skills but if you understand the logic
you can then take that logic and decide
i want to now become an expert in this
field an expert in the field of
transcriptomics or metagenomics or
genomics or some other direction and
really develop a whole
kind of a skill set around that and so
that was really the outcome for um her
in terms of her ability to define that
interest
to invest the time to really master a
lot of those skills and also for the
career development
to really be able to then showcase those
skills and the way that they have been
practically applied
so those are just a couple of examples
and now finally i want to finish with
our upcoming research symposium so we
already had
conducted two large events we had over a
thousand uh people who have registered
for each one of them and we had a great
panels of speakers from both industry
and academia showcasing advances in
bioinformatics and biomedical
informatics and talking about the
opportunities for students in terms of
their research and career
as they complete these kinds of training
programs and so what we have discovered
is that it is
very meaningful for researchers and
students from around the world to be
able to present their research and get
feedback from experts which comes not
only as a good or bad but really focuses
on the specifics of the research and
with a lot of feedback and so that
opportunity to both highlight your
research
get feedback from experts being able to
network and interact with them is
tremendously meaningful for people that
would like to continue or even begin in
this career
and really understand what their options
are and where this could lead to
so in terms of the summer research
fellowship the objective of this program
is to help you develop and complete a
project throughout the summer
and potentially participate in this
research symposium
networking with the people in industry
and academia getting feedback and maybe
identifying what that next step might be
a really critical component that a lot
of undergraduate students do not have
the option to
and so this is a unique opportunity to
get started and actually get it done in
the short time that we have during the
summer
so with that i'll pass it back to street
gory
and i hope to see you all in this
program that's coming up
all right thank you so much mr leo
brodsky
now we'll be launching a poll to better
understand our participants
so if you could take a moment to answer
the questions
the first is what is your educational or
research background
then the second question is which
specialization track are you interested
to work on
and
finally which skill set you want to get
hands on
so if you could just take a moment to
answer these questions
all right so let's move on to the next
part of the webinar
next up we have uh mr mohit mazumbar
uh he's the best business development
head at five biotech he has over 12
years of research and industry
experience and having a phd in
computational biology and chemistry from
jawaharlal nehru university india he is
also an expert in machine learning
applications in biomedical data and
chemical data he is currently heading
the global business development health
development for fine biotech usa and
contributing to bioinformatics research
and education by collaborating with
universities in india and africa and
mentoring participants from various
programs by providing bioinformatics
research support applying statistical
and algorithmic approaches
he will be talking about the research
fellowship fellowship university
relations and outcomes over to you
[Music]
all right thank you sri gauri and uh
thank you everyone including india and
uh dr raghavendran for giving us a clear
insight of how this research fellowship
program works so today uh i wanted to
discuss with you or meet with you all uh
to know you better and also to give you
the right kind of resources that would
be relevant to all of you
so based on your expectation and
the information that you have got to
join this meeting
we shared this poll so that we can
understand that where your interest lies
and then we can help you guide through
this research fellowship program so i
have a really
long experience working in this field of
computational biology i did my phd and
before that i did my master's in
bioinformatics and i was able to work on
several of these projects and completing
many of these and publishing a lot of
them so um i think in here as a mentor
uh one of my our responsibility is to
complete those analysis that we plan
that we work through so you saw the
structure uh in this meeting i wanted to
uh quickly take you through a couple of
things uh be before we all uh move to
the very excitement
experimentations where we have the
research fellow student research fellows
uh who would be presenting their work uh
quickly uh as we are running out of time
so uh before we move there i just wanted
to uh
ask everyone do you have these similar
questions in your mind if so then we
will be happy to answer some of these
questions in the chat and help you
understand how this works so i'll read
them out the questions that we have
that we get from the students all the
time so
the entire research fellowship program
can this program be a requirement for
the university internship uh yes and
i'll show you quickly the structure what
is the difference between three months
and six month program
so in a three months program we cover
most of the things that you that you saw
in this presentation including how to
work on a project and to complete a
project but within a six months time
because uh these projects they vary a
lot based on the research question they
vary a lot based on the group that is
working that it is working on
it also varies
based on the amount of time that you are
giving to this research relationship
program so based on all the time
requirements and the flexibility that we
offer this could be done in three months
six months and we usually have
this option given to students when they
have exams to pause the research
research fellowship and then start it
again after their examination
and um our about the hourly commitment
so how many hours hours commitment does
the research fellowship program requires
so it's again a question that kind of uh
is personalized
it depends on the number of hours that
is available for
the student and the mentor but usually
the way it works is that initially when
you're going through the course work and
understanding that how these all of
these components work uh you have to
give at least you know
three to four hours a day to understand
how uh how the course work is aligned
with the tbi info platform and the
example projects and that everyone has
to learn to be able to work on a
research project followed by that it is
more about you know finding the right
question doing the analysis where the
time can be managed according to your
own um schedule so what are the mental
mentorship options uh so we have a group
of mentors from uh industry from
academia from our own in our own company
um that includes all of us who are
present in this meeting so
based on the question we can assign or
we can suggest mentors who are expert in
this specific field
uh okay the next question can we choose
any topic uh yes
that requires you to go through the
course work and understand what are the
different areas of research uh where
what kind of research is ongoing and if
you can find specific publications and
prepare the project form that we
discussed then you can work on a topic
provided there is enough data for you to
work on
so the next question uh can we
participate in group projects yes uh
there's a great opportunity as we're
collaborating with
with industry as we are collaborating
with academia research labs there are
many projects that we are working on
which are cutting edge which requires
a lot of workflows where you can
participate and work on those group
projects they are also part of the
research fellowship program but it is
recommended that we
provide that sort of
opportunities for people who have
already at least completed one project
uh the next question can we publish our
project one of the major uh goal of this
research fellowship program is to be
able to highlight this research that you
have done in your own profile so
publishing your project gives you that
tremendous amount of you know exposure
and
makes you a part of the scientific
community so yes um and then the next
question the eighth question is about
prizing payment option and scholarship
so this research fellowship program
includes several of these resources that
we talked about that includes the
example projects that includes the basic
beginner coursework that includes the t
buy-in for platform server access that
includes the access to mentors group
sessions and this is an entire process
that develops your project so yes
there is some pricing options that are
available for anyone to join the
research fellowship program but it is
also advised as advisable to understand
this that uh may all of this payment is
going for the
resources that you have been provided
with
help students from low income countries
for students who have financial
difficulties in doing a program we
provide scholarships from our end and
also from universities whom we have
collaborated and offering these programs
in together
so uh furthermore if you have any more
questions
i will request all of you to put it in
the chat box and our team will be happy
to assist you and we will be reaching
out to you specifically to answer any
questions that you have
about the
specific topics that we discussed and
also these questions that we have put
together
so um now moving on i just wanted to um
like discuss about our university
collaborations and how all of these
resources are helping a university
develop student capacity as well as
develop research projects as well as
develop grants and publication so um i
mean uh to discuss about we have already
discussed about these all of these uh
topics in detail so we have beginner
coursework for students who are really
new to this field who would want to
start their journey and would want to
work on a project eventually so we have
a detailed coursework that enables
anyone so most of our students who are
coming from the background which is
mostly biotechnology microbiology
even computer science so this course
work is built for biologists it's meant
for biologists to learn data science to
learn biomedical data science to learn
bioinformatics and apply to a real
project so there is a beginner
coursework which is very detailed for
anyone without a background to learn and
apply this
then we have these specific course work
on multi-genomics fields big data
bioinformatics where you will learn that
how do you see these data how do you
visualize such a big amount of data and
make meaningful information get
meaningful information from there by
using several of these tools including
the t by info multi-omics platform that
helps again the beginners and anyone to
get that infrastructure run experiments
analyze data from a very easy to use
point-and-click system the the one of
the purpose of making this as a simple
system is that the logic of analysis the
um the meaning of the research
can be understood and that is one of the
main focus of this research fellowship
training this research fellowship
program and we are really
happy with the outcomes that students
are getting from this because they are
understanding why they are doing it and
then they are performing the research so
followed by that we have this difference
very specialization the kind of research
that
excites everyone that we have in this
omics omixologic research where you can
work on specialization fields such as
spaceomex and then you can work on very
difficult problems such as cancer and
for all for all of this i mean after
doing the basic training the research
training you start you're doing your
exploratory analysis and do your
literature review and followed by that
data analysis and interpretation so
that's the training part and that is
well uh discussed in this meeting and i
hope that it's kind of clear to all of
you if not we will be again sharing with
you uh the resources that will help you
understand
so uh the technical training we
discussed this um there are several of
these
data types that we are using patient for
clinical data animal models where these
experiments have been tested many of the
drugs have been tested which starts from
a cell line experiments uh eventually
and then we understand analyze processes
and annotate and integrate this sort of
data for many purposes such as drug
discovery which is a very important
thing that you learned from this
precision medicine talk today and by the
help of
tools such as the t-band for platform
and coding languages such as python and
r we had been able to do downstream
analysis which is really good for all of
that uh things that we want to highlight
like a poster presentation like uh like
the presentation that you do for your
university or for a grant
so that's the technical training part
followed by that we have the
introductory course work then the
example projects that you have seen then
we have the specialization training and
then you work on a research projects
with very defined steps so because of
all of this i mean that's the reason we
have been able to do it
challenging so all of this is well
structured there is a help in within
every step there is support within every
step for students from different
background from different educational
and geographical location
now uh as you have learned about the
entire process like this entire process
of understanding and writing
uh all of this is also supported by uh
faculty projects so once you have gone
through these steps uh we align your
interest with the faculty project with
the partner university that we have and
we have faculties who have proposed
projects whom we are working with and
are uh more uh you know focused towards
the translational outcome more focused
about you know getting publications and
getting that recognition so these are
some of the opportunities that we
provide to students to work with faculty
who have these defined projects and uh
who can help further giving you the
right kind of feedback to develop your
project
so
that is what i wanted to show you all in
uh in this short presentation that i
have put together but uh before i leave
and pass it to this to sri gauri to help
students come and discuss about their
research i wanted to tell you about
couple of opportunities so we have
campus ambassador opportunities um and
also scholarship opportunities and
internship opportunities these are for
students who are well-versed with omis
logic and would want to represent
omixlogic in their campuses or in would
want to work with us
in our within our team to help
awareness of bioinformatics so these are
some of the opportunities again for the
participants who are in the us and who
are in louisiana area and also who are
those who are connected with the nepa
network
we are offering many of these training
programs starting from june
uh to this
to the students who will be
pre-registering and will be reaching out
to help them register for these uh
fully uh sponsored programs uh
where the students are studying in this
universities and also we are providing
50 and above scholarships for students
who are coming from outside and who want
to be a part of these programs these
training programs which is more of to
you know give you an understanding of
how the different data types can be
analyzed for a specific specialization
and also like the research fellowship
program is being offered in the u.s and
if you are in the u.s you cannot avail
that program if you are in india and if
you are in
africa you can avail the program and
details that we are sharing with you in
this meeting so that's about it and um i
i would like to pass this back to shri
to invite quickly students and we have
very less time like we have only 14
minutes left in this meeting so we will
just conclude accordingly and have a few
presentations and rest we will be able
to send you
through video recording thank you so
much
all right and next
we'll have the much awaited research
fellows presenting their research uh
projects first up we have miss huian
pham she will be
presenting her research project on spike
glycoprotein sequences of star cov2
analysis variant analysis over to um
um hello everyone so i'm gonna present
on covet 19 final synthetic analysis um
so uh the project that i did at pi
biotech for research fellows so i will
skip the introductions and go directly
to the material
um
so the variance sequence collect from
ncbi virus uh including uh several
variants of concerns uh
for analysis
then um
i use uh
the pybo uh type of
parabolic uh tech platform uh to analyze
multiple sequence alignments and
generate uh the
phylogenetic tree
um
so overall of the process is here uh
this is the picture of the pipeline
uh and here is the results
so um this would enable me to
observe the
evolutionary relationship between
sequence
and uh to look at it further um i also
thought about the multiple sequence
alignment side and here uh was something
i found
um this will include uh the positions
that is less conservative uh insurance
deletion regions
um
yeah so here is the zoom out of uh
of those that have high very variations
after that i map it into the protein
that was from
the bdb
um
and then
i found some results that um most of the
paper uh just mentions about the
substitutions
[Music]
mutations are related to the increase in
viral adaptedness so from the study
i find some
new thing that is the deletions
instructions regions so
i suggest that it may be uh due to the
imperfections during recombinations
because the virus
have high
recombination rate so this could
facilitate some um deletions and
instructions at a particular site
so
yeah so that is the overall of my wishes
so there's also some limitations uh that
is uh
some
instructions and deletions regions that
make the multiple sequel alignments
slightly of the check
so um
i hope that uh
it may be in uh improved in the futures
uh so that we have a better alignment at
some site
so in conclusions so
so understanding about the viral rates
and type of the mutations can help us to
understand about the virus the
evolutionary of the virus and get the
best strategies for prevention
so
um it also can help us to find some site
that uh have
potentials of mutations in the future
and predict the structure
um so that we have better strategy to
keep with uh
the high mutation rate of the virus
yeah so that is
the end of my presentation
thank you so much
um
you can also view rest of the research
fellow projects on the omixlogic portal
next we will discuss about the research
fellowship registration and it will be
discussed by ms sunalika ray she is the
community manager
uh over to you
thank you so much
i would
like to the screen just a second
any questions please put them in the
chat box and i'll be shortly taking you
through the registration process so
today we discussed about the research
fellowship program the structure of the
program and the different specialization
tracks that are being covered and also
we heard it from
and we also have more research project
presentations that you can
explore on the onyx logic learn portal
so now those who are interested to get
themselves registered for the fellowship
program
where do they uh go and proceed their
application
uh from so this is the
misogyny that you all saw and you need
to click on the research button over
here this will redirect you to the
research fellowship registration page
now once you are on this page i'll just
share the link in the chat box
yeah so now once you are here on this uh
page you need to click on the get
started button which will give you a
pop-up listing the
fellowship amount for beginner and
advanced level
for three months and six months
if you are a researcher who wants to
explore data from the big data
repositories and
work on your analysis and complete your
project then the beginner level works
the best for you but if you are working
in a lab generating your own data set
and you want to explore your your own
data so then uh taking the advanced
level will be more helpful
so the cost for the beginner level for
three months is dollar two to five and
for the advanced level installer 297 and
for the six months of subscription you
double the amount so now
why do we have a fee structure for the
research fellowship program it's because
you get the access to the omixological
research resources the training
resources and also the tea buyer info
server that dr raghav either talked
about where you get five terabyte of
space and also you get allocated to the
to these research fellowship batch
meetings where you are able to
take your queries from the mentor and
get your questions clarified
and now talk about the research
scholarship opportunities that you can
leverage
so those uh who come from uh bachelors
and masters uh the students who come
from various fields of life sciences
from battles and masters and they feel
the need to get a scholarship they can
definitely fill out the scholarship fund
so i'm going to share with you the
scholarship form and also you will be
able to fill out the form uh and reach
out to ms parsh third she's our business
development associate and she'll be able
to assist you with your scholarship so
once you fill out the scholarship form
we'll review your application and get
back to you
now to fill your scholarship you need to
visit
the page here
scroll down and you'll get the
registration form towards the end of the
scholarship page
after you fill out the scholarship
application we'll review your
application and get back to you most
probably will also show you a meeting
with you and listen to your research and
trust and educational background and
also if you have a research proposal
then it would be great
so that was uh very briefly what i
discussed about how you can get yourself
registered for the research fellowship
program and get started with your
independent project journey
if you have any questions you can put
them in the chat box and
also you can reach out to us at
marketing
at the amislogic.com thank you so much
for sharing the details and also sparsh
has shared our indian contact number
where you can reach out to her and
she'll help you with your enrollment
process
also we uh provide scholarships to our
partner university students so those who
are from amity university noida jaipur
and uh chennai group of colleges please
feel free to reach out to us and also
other students who are seeking fellow a
scholarship please feel free to fill out
the scholarship form i'll put the
scholarship form once again in the chat
box for you and also you can reach out
to spurs in uh on our mail address for
any assistance
that was it for today and thank you
everyone for joining today's meet